we all know someone right now in our
life or we have who's not ethical who's
not a good person who's winning and
you're like I can't believe they're
getting it any artists any person but
especially artists have to know they're
wide that effortless action that just
sort of allowing oh I was thinking about
that and it just showed up that's how
life is supposed to be we get in the way
what's that believe nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so today let's help you
live your best believe life and learn
the power of belief and how it can
change your life also if you want to
know what simon Sinek tom bill you and
others have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 250
for confidence series where every day
for the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below the skill to hold
your opinions to yourself there's a gap
between who people are and what they
tell you they want to accomplish even
though I'm gonna sell you the most
beautiful hammer I'm not gonna guarantee
the structural integrity of the house
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one alter your beliefs with Ed Mallette
so there's this Governor on our lives
and it is a governor and it's a it's
your identity it's this internal it's
what you think you're worth it's what
you think you deserve and the problem
for good people see we all know someone
right now in our life where we have
who's not ethical who's not a good
person who's winning and you're like I
can't believe they're getting it right
why can't I I'm a good person I treat
people while I'm honest here's a reason
why by the way the unethical person
eventually karma you reap what you sow
comes home to roost but if you're a good
person this is so important people
understand this because it took me a
long time a good person in any endeavor
will only take from it what they think
they deserve what they think they're
worth in other words if there was a
pizza here you're a good person you
don't take all 12 pieces a good person
thinks there should be an equitable
distribution layer so I might take seven
or eight arm-wrestle you I don't know
about that your moose butt but long
story short what is is that you a good
person will not take more from the table
of life than they think they're worth or
they think they deserve and so you have
this Governor on your identity so what
happens is our it's like a thermostat
our lives get going we start doing
really well if we're a 75 degree or and
our life gets to 85 and 90 degrees
unconsciously we go we don't know we're
doing it well we start to cool life back
down to get it back to where we're
comfortable that reverse is also true
when things start to go really bad and
you're broke and you're struggling you
find a way to heat your life back up to
what you think you're worth and you
deserve so the way we alter our life is
sure we got alter our behavior and our
relationships and our circumstances but
the only way it's permanent is that we
alter that governor that thermostat and
we start to believe we're worth
eighty-five degrees of life 95 degrees
of life 110 degrees of life and there's
ways we can alter that how do we alter
it a couple different ways a one is what
you just said is that you put yourself
in circumstances that are demanding if
you pass what you think your capacity is
and when you succeed at them you build a
new water line you do you throw yourself
out there past where your comfort
and you do at 85° behavior and you knock
it out of the park and go your brain
starts to believe it repetitiously when
you start doing that you build a new
line now your 85° that's number one
the second way though is Association if
you're around people and whatever that
endeavor is if it's a sport you're in or
if it's a business or your faith or your
peace if you begin to associate with
people who live in that space at a
higher temperature than you through
association you get heat it up yeah so
if you're an athlete for example you're
a 70-degree athlete and you start
training all the time with 85 and 90
degrees your identity through osmosis
goes up if your person is trying to
improve their faith in their life or
their their personal piece about them
you all know this you've seen it when
you start to hang around people that are
a little bit more peaceful than you or
meditate a little bit more through that
association over time the thermostat
changes in that area and so it's both
behaving in certain way and then your
associations yeah I believe that
rule number two break the limiting
beliefs with Jordan Belfort the second
thing is your beliefs essentially the
beliefs that you hold about yourself
about your capabilities about money
whether your beliefs that attract money
to you or that propel money whether that
you have beliefs that allow you to move
through barriers and obstacles or
beliefs that cause you to shy away from
barriers and obstacles and the beliefs
that we have really control our actions
we don't typically go at things or do
things that we believe we're not good at
we don't take actions everything we're
gonna fail we shy away and then of
course we don't say that we're scared we
come up with a story
so the sort of these negative these
limiting beliefs Institut instigate
that's telling the [ __ ] stories to
ourselves right and it holds us back
from success so the idea is that is to
understand what your core limiting
beliefs are and then to actually break
those beliefs and you can do that's not
that difficult to do it do it in a
seminar setting you break the limiting
beliefs and you essentially empower
somebody by helping them install their
own beliefs in themselves because your
beliefs are malleable you can change
them so the idea is to essentially
retrofit your beliefs to serve you and
your outcomes in a case of entrepreneurs
stuff and money is not the root of all
evil that building the business as
possible that I
and Lerman a very noble sort of beliefs
right rule number three express your why
with simon Sinek i went to see a play
with a friend of mine who is an actor
and the play was awful I mean a train
wreck the script was awful the directing
was awful I mean it was an absolute
train wreck the question you asked was
about collaboration right should any of
those actors have taken the part now of
course if you're gonna take a part
because you need an extra cash little
extra cash or you want to get little
extra practice then you have to do so I
think knowing I'm doing this for the
money
or I'm doing this just to keep keep my
skills sharp but I'm under no illusion
that this is something that I connect
with but I'm gonna do the best that I
can and then don't lie to yourself you
know the other problem is don't do that
too often because that'll just destroy
any passion that you have for your
medium right and I think and we've
talked about this which is which is any
artist any person but especially artists
have to know their why you have to know
why you're showing up in the first place
and you have to be able to talk about it
because if you talk about it things
happen people go I like you right now
you may not get the part but you're more
likely to find people who want to work
with you even if you're not the most
talented one who auditioned this is my
career by the way right when I learned
to talk about what I believed I didn't
talk about the things I've done I didn't
talk about the parts I've had or the
shows I've been in or who trained me
where the schools I went to resume
resume resume I started I learned to
talk about what I believed and some
people thought it was cheesy they didn't
call me back
good and some people went that's great
and I was not the most talented not the
most experienced not the best at my
field but because they stood for or
believed in what I stood for they wanted
to work with me they would rather work
with someone who under
who got them more than somebody who
would just take orders and do exactly
what they wanted regardless of facility
rule number four manifest what you want
with Gabby Bernstein so for our audience
can you define what exactly is
manifesting manifesting is acquiring the
experience of what it is that you want
to feel and being and living and
believing in that experience and then
allowing that experience to come in to
form manifesting is very creative it is
the process of using your power energy
and being in that presence of your
high-powered energy and allowing that
energy to co-create with the energy
that's around you so you're vibrating at
a high frequency I'm vibrating at a
frequency we done a lot of work we've
got cleaned up a lot of our own crap we
now leaving ourselves today yeah and
that act that energy of believing in
ourselves has attracted us together
today and brought us into this space
where we together are co-creating and
teaching if I hadn't cleaned up my side
of the street and if I didn't believe in
myself the way I do I would never have
manifested being on marietv there's a
really nice line from A Course in
Miracles which is the metaphysical text
I teach and it is miracles occur
naturally and when they're not occurring
something has gone wrong that is an
interesting it's a good one right so
what happens is is that that
synchronicity that flow that effortless
action that just sort of allowing oh I
was thinking about that and it just
showed up that's how life is supposed to
be we get in the way our negative belief
systems our fears our anxiety our anger
towards the past that future tripping
and projecting all of that energy gets
in the way of allowing all of the
miracles to occur naturally and rule
number five the last one before a very
special bonus clip is change your
beliefs with Tom billion the matrix has
you now the matrix to me is a simple
metaphor I don't actually believe that
we're living in the computer simulation
and even if we are I don't think that it
matters but what does matter is your
entire life is being lived by your brain
now what do I mean by that if you know a
guy named David Eagleman he wrote a book
called incognito in the book incognito
he makes one thing abundantly clear you
live in a virtual environment whether
you realize it or not that
virtual environment is created by the
three pounds of squishing material
between your ears
think about this your brain never
touches light your brain is encased in a
bone box in total darkness and yet it
takes photons that fall on the eye and
turns it into electrochemical stimulus
and from that it paints this environment
it fakes the sense of depth think about
this for a second there's not some
little image of this room projected into
the back of my mind this is all being
turned into electrochemical stimulus and
my brain then manufactures this
environment there's actually a dime spot
blank part in your field of vision where
each optic nerve connects to your eyes
and yet you have no experience of it
that it's completely invisible to you
even though it's massive and it's dead
center in your eyes the reason that you
don't experience it is because your
brain fills it in your brain makes a
guess as to what would be there and your
brain is so good at guessing and so good
at presenting it as if it were real that
you have no sense it is completely
seamless to you when I heard that I
remember getting the chills and setting
the book down and saying my brain is
lying to me that rat now the question
becomes if this is all made up if the
sense of distance between you and I is
completely manufactured by my brain and
it's not real meaning what I see of it
it's real enough and that if I walk I'll
hit you at about the point that I'm
expecting to bump into you because my
brain can create that sense of distance
but it's doing it by translating those
signals it's manufacturing this space so
if that's true and my brain fills in the
gaps does my brain also have biases and
the answer is yes neuroscience has gone
deep into how many different biases that
we have as humans I'll give you one
because this one is profoundly impactful
you're more likely to believe something
negative than you are something positive
now think about how that can echo
through your life each of us has to
realize that all of the beliefs that we
have in our
life our choices the scary part about
the most important beliefs in your life
as most of them are invisible I'm going
to give you a couple questions that will
highlight invisible beliefs that you
have that are controlling your life that
are exactly why I say the matrix has you
because depending on how you answer
these questions will determine your life
and if you don't recognize something
scary in your own answers think about
the people that you love that you want
to help and you can't and you wonder why
the answer is almost certainly related
to how they answer some of these
questions number one this comes from
Einstein he said the most important
decision the most important decision any
human being must make is whether or not
you live in a friendly or a hostile
universe now we could have said
realization but he didn't he said
decision you have to decide because
there is no empirical truth you don't
live in either a friendly or a hostile
universe you decide and that perception
that viewpoint from which you judge
everything else that happens in your
life will be colored by whether or not
you think it is a universe that is
working for you or against you and it's
a choice but most people think of their
viewpoint is being patently real as
being just objective and true and so
they never stop to question the fact
that they actually decided that at some
point either because their parents acted
in accordance with that it was either
hostile or friendly and they just
absorbed that or their friends or the
people that they work with or whatever
but somewhere along the line they came
to believe that they live in either a
friendly or a hostile universe but you
could change right now right now you
could make a different decision and if
you believe that the world is working
against you right now
you could choose to believe that it's
actually working for you and in making a
fundamentally new and different
assumption it empowers you to move
forward and this is something that I
will repeat in this talk the reason that
matters is human beings do not invest
energy in things that they don't think
will yield a result
now I've got a really special bonus clip
from Jack Canfield on how to change your
limiting beliefs but before that it's
time for the three-point landing
questions time to move from just
watching another video to actually
taking action in your life or your
business and if you feeling bold leave
your responses in the comments below
here we go question number one what
limiting belief are you currently
holding on to number two how are you
going to break it and number three what
is your why
now another mistake you might have
normally be making and therefore
sabotaging your unhappiness with is
allowing yourself to be controlled by
your limiting beliefs
many of us have beliefs that limit our
success whether their beliefs about our
own capabilities beliefs about what it
takes to succeed or even beliefs about
how we should relate to other people now
moving beyond your limiting beliefs is a
critical step toward becoming happier
and more successful and then do this you
must first believe that you're capable
of accomplishing your goals and you're
capable of being happy and here's a
simple but powerful four-step process
you can use to transform any limiting
belief into an empowering belief the
first step is identify a limiting belief
that you want to change the second step
is to determine how that belief is
limiting you now the third step is to
decide how you would rather be act or
feel and a fourth step is to create a
turnaround statement that affirms or
gives you permission to be to act or to
feel this new way for example a negative
belief might be if I express my true
feelings people will think I'm weak and
take advantage of me
now the turnaround belief would be the
more I express my true feelings the more
people love respect admire and support
me now once you've created a new belief
you will need to implant it into your
subconscious mind through constant
repetition for two or three minutes
several times a day for a minimum of 30
days
[Music]
yeah the most important work ever if you
had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be collect a little beacon
[Music]
if you liked this video and you want to
know what best advice millionaires have
check the video link right there next to
me I think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there use your
life to be a light to somebody else's
let's find a gamble slows you're the
house